(dramatic music)
- So ultimately I want to make the point
that in such a world, growth and equality
are not only, they're not substitutes,
they are strong compliments.
- So welcome to the 30th
Kuznets Memorial Lecture
presented by the Economic Growth Center.
I'm Rohini Pande, I'm a professor
at the Economics Department
and director of EGC.
Because this lecture is an annual lecture
on issues in economic development
given by prominent economists
in memory of Simon Kuznets,
the famous Belarusian-American economist.
Kuznets was not a Yale professor,
but he was instrumental in founding EGC.
In 1934, Kuznets helped launch
the US national income statistics series.
the motivation was to use data for policy.
The series was issued to meet the need
to describe consistently and in detail,
the economic tool taken
by the Great Depression.
Post World War II, as
colonialism, the big question was
what would drive economic development
in the poorer parts of the world?
'Cause that's our reason
for a center to do something
that its home institution
were not able to,
to use data to describe development.
And so he turned to Yale
to set up the institute,
which is now known as EGC.
EGC was arguably the first
development research center
in a major US university that focused
on using quantitative methods
to understand economic development.
Today, as we gain access to greater data
and improve computation
power and estimation methods,
economists are responding
to Kuznets' call of 1934,
which was to say the welfare
of a nation can scarcely
be inferred from a measurement
of national income alone,
to look at broader measures of inequality.
This burning focus of development
research will be the theme
of Professor Goldberg's lecture tonight,
and of the conference that
she will lead tomorrow.
When it comes to bridging
inequalities based on gender,
it takes bold women to be
willing to be the first
to enter spaces previously held by men.
Penny Goldberg is one such woman.
She was the first female
professor to be given tenure
by the Yale economic department.
She was the first female editor-in-chief
of the American Economic Review.
And as president-elect of the
Econometrics Society for 2021,
she will be its first female president.
More recently, Penny served
as only the second ever
female chief economist of the
World Bank after Ann Krueger,
who also happened to
be the only other woman
to have delivered the Kuznets lecture
in its 30-year history.
Penny's research takes
on important questions
in trade and development.
She studied last trade
liberalization episodes
in developing countries.
Her work has drawn out the
contrasting implications
of trade reform in India and Latin America
for product markets and inequality.
Her most recent research
examines the resurgence
of protectionism in the
US and the interplay
between informality and
trade liberalization.
Penny is someone whose work
I've admired for a long time
and she has been an
important role model for me
and many other women in the profession.
So this year as Yale
celebrates the 50th anniversary
of the matriculation of
women in Yale College,
and the 150th anniversary
of the first women students
in the university, it seems
particularly appropriate
that we welcome this
pioneering woman to deliver
the 13th Kuznets Memorial Lecture.
Please welcome Professor Goldberg.
(audience applauding)
- Hello, first of all,
Rohini thank you so much
for this very generous introduction.
I'm very happy to be back, for good now.
Yale has been a wonderful
home to me for many years,
and I'm looking forward to
assuming back my academic duties.
But today I'm going to talk
still, as chief economist
of the World Bank Group, I have
three more days on my term.
And the reason I mentioned that is not
because there's going
to be any juicy gossip.
If that's what you're here for
I'm afraid I'm going to disappoint you.
But because When picking
the topic for this lecture,
I did try to be consistent with the theme
of Kuznet's research,
which as Rohini mentioned,
was very much focused on
inequality and growth.
But also I wanted to build
on my World Bank experience
for the past two years.
So I'm going to draw on this.
And what this means is I will start
with some preliminary
thoughts about the perspective
that one has from the chief economist's
Office of the World Bank.
What I mean by that, so
one advantage of being
at the World Bank is that one gets exposed
to what I would call the big
picture questions in economics.
And for the past few years,
there has been a tendency
to focus on smaller questions,
at least in research in economics,
questions that we can address very well,
but the scope of them
tends to be more narrow.
Perhaps many of you have seen
a very well known lecture
by one of the Nobel Prize
winners this year, Esther Duflo.
She gave the lecture Ely few years ago
when the title of the Ely Lecture
was The Economist as a Plumber.
And there she made the point
that it's very important
for economists to get the
details of implementation,
of policy implementation right
because it doesn't matter
how good your policy is,
if you don't get the details right,
the policy is going to come to nothing.
I love this lecture, I very
much believe in this message.
And after being at the World
Bank for for a year and a half,
I believe in this message even
more strongly than before.
That said, I think one should not forget
that in order to build
a functional building,
you need the plumber, but
you also need the architect
and the engineer.
And as much as I believe that some of us
should spend time on
implementation and plumbing,
I also think some of us
should also spend some time
on the big picture questions in economics
and trying to figure out how
everything fits together.
And the point, in the World Bank,
you are forced to do that all the time,
partly because you
interact with countries,
with finance ministers, with policymakers.
And they really want more from you
than how a specific project will work,
they will want to know what
your vision for development is.
Which brings me to one of the
motivations of this lecture.
I'm going to make the point
that we're at a point in time
where we need a new vision,
a new model for development.
I will explain what I mean in a moment.
So I think that was one very
positive aspect of being
at the World Bank, you're forced to think
about these questions.
The other thing that's very
different in the World Bank
compared to academia, is that
you are constantly forced
to think in cross country terms.
And as I'm sure you all know,
cross country regressions
have become an anathema in a
political work in academics.
Many people don't take
them seriously anymore.
But in the World Bank, this
is often the foundation
of giving advice to countries.
So countries will often
come to you and say,
you are the World Bank, you've
been to all these countries,
you know what works in country A,
can't you tell us how we could
apply it to our own country.
So you're constantly forced to think
in this cross country terms,
to run cross country regressions
in your head all the time.
They actually think that
this is very productive,
which is a good thing to do
as long as you understand
the limitations of this and you don't use,
you don't confine yourself to
a straitjacket of regression,
and pretend that you have
absolutely robust scientific evidence.
So I mentioned that because
what I'm going to talk about
is going to be built on these
observations in some sense.
I'm going to employ some
cross country analysis.
And I'm going to rely
a lot on correlations
rather than clean identification,
but I think some correlations
can be actually quite informative.
So I'll use, this is not going to be
the standard academic talk.
I'm going to use many
pictures and correlations
to just tell a story.
So as I said, I think
there is great demand
among policymakers these
days for a new vision
for development that I'll be
more specific in a moment.
At the same time, there is great demand
especially among advanced economies,
among industrialized
countries for more equality
or less inequality.
So the focus of policy in many countries
in the last few years has been
on inequality not on poverty.
Poverty seems almost a forgotten word
outside the World Bank.
And whenever in the world
ranking, in talks or seminars,
I made a point for more equality,
I immediately got pushback from countries,
from poor countries that ask,
does this mean you give up on growth?
We don't care about inequality,
for us growth is much more important.
And what underlies this comment
is this very strongly
held view among economists
that there is a trade off
between growth and inequality.
And of course, this trade
off is to a certain extent
based on the famous
Kuznets curve that posited
that there is a trade off at least
in the early stages of development,
there is a trade off between
growth and inequality
as an economy grows.
Then inequality rises, but
eventually it tapers off.
So I will have something
to say about that too.
So, with that introduction,
let me give you
a more specific roadmap for this talk.
I will start by explaining
what I mean by the old model
of development that was
based to a large extent
on export led industrialization.
This is a model, perhaps it
has been not that influential
in academia, but it has,
it was the cornerstone of
advice that the World Bank
or the IMF and many other institutions,
international institutions gave.
Then I will talk about the recent retreat
from globalization and multilateralism
we've experienced in the last few years.
and I will make the
point that this retreat
actually poses a challenge
for this old model.
And that also gives rise to this need
for a new vision for development.
And regarding this new vision,
there are various proposals
that are made fairly casually actually
in the development world.
One of them is leapfrogging
into the service sector,
skipping the manufacturing stage.
Another one concerns
urbanization led development.
And finally, what I really
want to talk about today
is the idea that if we
transition to a world
that's more closed, less
open with less trade,
with less globalization,
then domestic markets
become more important.
And if domestic markets
become more important,
then a certain degree of equality
may become an important
precondition for growth.
So ultimately, I want to make the point
that in such a world,
growth and equality are not
only, they're not substitutes,
they are strong complements.
So when I make this point, of
course, the way I express it,
it's very general and open ended.
So I will try to make it more
concrete by operationalizing
this notion of the domestic
market and to do that,
that's when you need a
conceptual framework.
So I will talk a little bit
about the theoretical framework
that one can use to
think about these issues
and then some empirical work
that I've been recently working
on and present some results.
And eventually, as I said,
the point I want to make
and this will be the conclusion in case
you fall asleep or you
have to leave early.
For a small car, it's nearly impossible
if not completely impossible
to eliminate poverty
if this country remains closed.
So openness to trade
is extremely important.
So, when we mean openness in that context,
openness these days means more than trade,
it means deep integration.
So with deep integration, I
mean, essentially measures
that make sure that
whatever trade agreements
you have are enforceable,
but also measures
that contribute to stronger capital
and labor flows between countries.
Alternatively, if you don't have this path
that involves more openness, more trade,
and if you need to focus
on the domestic market,
larger countries have it easier.
If you're in India, you're going to have
an easier time growing because you control
the domestic market.
But in such a setting,
it's important to have
a certain degree of
equality that will support
the emergence of a healthy middle class,
so that the purchasing
power of this middle class
can support development.
So this is where I'm going with this.
And let me now be a little more specific.
So as I said, I will start by explaining
what the old model of export-led
industrialization has been.
So what's this model?
So this model is part of the
so called Washington Consensus.
And these terms have become
extremely controversial
but actually, if you think about
what the Washington Consensus involved,
it involved a set of many
policies, a set of policies,
many of which actually
are fairly reasonable
from an economist point of view.
Three of the most important pillars
of this Washington
Consensus, were deregulation,
privatization and trade liberalization.
So embracing open international markets.
And the idea there was as follows.
So, if we apply this model
to developing countries,
developing countries are
abundant in low skilled labor,
low wage labor.
So by engaging in free
trade, in open trade,
they can utilize their
comparative advantage.
And this comparative advantage is most,
can be most utilized
in basic manufacturing.
By exporting to higher income countries,
a lot of good things happen.
As I mentioned, they can utilize
their comparative advantage.
In addition, they can tap
into the purchasing power
of richer countries.
If you were China in the 80s,
or Vietnam in the early 90s,
you don't need to rely
on a rich domestic market
to sell your products.
You can rely on the richer consumers
in the United States or Europe.
Of course, you can
realize economies of scale
from selling to the global
market, and hence industrialize.
And finally, you can use
all the export revenue
to finance investments in
infrastructure or human capital.
So investments that are going
to give you the foundations
for long run development.
So this kind of model
that has been applied
to many countries, mostly in East Asia
is logically consistent.
You can see how the various parts work.
By the way, here I'm
presenting a verbal feature
of these models,
international trade economists
have spent many years building models
that formalize these ideas.
So the model has been disputed
that it's logically consistent.
It's a framework that we understand.
You can disagree with it, but
once you have the framework,
you know how to attack
it and how to take issue
with some of these assumptions.
But I would say overall, it
has been actually supported
by casual observer and evidence.
And here I'm thinking, of
course, mostly of what happened
in East Asia, especially China.
So let me give you the
story in a few pictures.
And as I said, I'm going to
rely here on correlations.
So you're not going to
see any regressions,
claiming identification.
The modern era, so post World War II
and this starts in 1827, okay?
And on the vertical axis, our exports,
global exports as percentage of GDP.
So you can see, there is some variations
in this percentage over time.
Here, that's 1945 and after 1945,
so after World War II, exports
start rising very fast.
This year, this is the
period of what people call
the hyperglobalisation, when
trade starts growing very fast
as a percentage of GDP.
And this is partly
powered by the emergence
of global value chains
and the emergence of
fragmentation in production.
So this is a global phenomenon,
it's not driven by specific countries.
So here you can see
essentially the same picture.
So here, fortunately,
the numbers came out.
And you can see for the
world, all this is essentially
the previous graph.
But you can also see it
for selected countries.
And what's interesting
here, I want to point out
is if you look at the USA,
this is the new blue line here.
You see it trend upwards, but for the US,
this trend is not that pronounced.
And the reason, part of the reason is
the US is already a very
large, rich country.
So trade is important for the US.
But it's not as important for
the US as it is for countries
that are still poor.
It's of course, very important for China.
This is China, and many
people say hyperglobalization,
the increasing trade is driven by China.
China is clearly an
important part of the story.
But it's not just China,
it's many other countries.
For example, it's India,
that's the green line here.
So here I put some of
the biggest countries.
But you can see also more
clearly in this graph
that shows the composition
of world exports
by income groups.
And this is based on a classification
that the World Bank uses.
The World Bank makes a distinction
between high income countries
and then between upper middle
income, lower middle income
and low income countries.
And this classification
here is based on 1987.
So it's time invariant.
So for example, China was a
low income country in '87.
By now it's upper middle income.
But for the purpose of this graph,
China will always appear
in the low income category.
So you can see in '85,
if we take countries
other than the high income countries,
cumulatively, they accounted
for about 13% of total exports,
world exports, and that makes sense.
Most of the economic activity
comes from the rich countries
as you would expect.
So by 2015, if you take
the cumulative share
of upper middle income,
lower middle income
and low income countries is about 33%.
So it has increased
dramatically, and that part
is driven to a very large extent by China.
But again, it's not only China,
many other developing countries
have participated in this phenomenon.
Now, what has this done for
poverty across the world?
At the same time, we had
a very sharp reduction
in global poverty and global
inequality across the world.
And of course, you're
going to say that there
are many factors that drove this decrease.
It's not just trade,
and perhaps the most
important one was peace.
You cannot have growth and
prosperity and poverty reduction
unless you have peace,
and that's certainly true.
But I will also make the point that trade
has played an important role.
And this is not something
that you can show
through a regression
that is going to address
all concerns you may have
regarding identification.
But I do think that if
we take the evidence
that has been accumulated over the years
and by that I mean regressions,
I mean anecdotal evidence
and anecdotal accounts.
I mean that many case
studies that actually
my predecessor at the
World Bank, Ann Krueger,
conducted 30 years ago,
mostly on East Asia
and Southeast Asia.
Then all these studies
together tell the story
of trade contributing to
growth and poverty reduction.
Not to mention the recent experience,
the relatively recent experience of China
and Vietnam and Korea.
And this story is also
reflected in a series of books.
So I will mention a few here.
Deaton's "The Great Escape".
So this is a book that's extremely
critical of the World Bank
but it does make the point
that globalization has
contributed very significantly
to the great escape, and the great escape
is the great escape from poverty.
There is the World Bank report,
world Development Report
from 2006 and that report
also made the point,
the very important point at that time,
that if we think about
inequality, not within borders,
but globally about the difference,
the discrepancy between the wellbeing
of the globally rich
and the globally poor,
this has been dramatically
reduced post World War II.
And one of the persons who worked
on that world development report
was actually Branko Milanovic,
who after he left the World
Bank, he actually worked
on the book of his book,
"Global Inequality".
So the book became a bestseller
and it made him truly famous.
And that's again a book
that makes this point
that global inequality,
by global inequality, in some sense
you can take that as a synonym for poverty
has been reduced dramatically
post World War II.
And again globalization has played
a very important role in all this.
And that raises also the question
that's actually a question
that Branko Milanovic
explicitly asked in his book,
whether there is actually a trade off
between global inequality and
within country inequality.
So one of his hypotheses
is that this reduction
in global inequality has
happened at the expense
of an increase in domestic inequality.
Some more pictures that tell this story.
And I think these are very telling.
This is the very famous elephant curve.
So the blue part comes from Branko,
from actually Branko
Milanovic beats and Lakner.
Actually the green part was later added
by Carol Freund.
So what this elephant, so I will call this
the old elephant curve
because it has been updated.
I'll show you in a moment how.
But what this elephant curve shows
is on the horizontal axis,
you have the percentiles
of the global income distribution.
So this is taking the world's population,
putting it together, and then
looking at the percentiles
of this distribution.
And then on the vertical axis,
you have the income growth rate.
In percentage terms, this
is per capita income.
And this is all between
'88 and 2008, okay?
So precisely this period
includes precisely
the period of the hyperglobalization.
It is during this period, where
you see the fastest growth
in these percentiles.
These are actually the world's poor.
So, according to that figure,
it's mostly the world's poor
that have benefited the most from growth.
Of course, the very
rich also benefit a lot.
So the very top 1%, but
this is the main message
of this curve was that poverty,
that the growth was such that
actually poverty declined.
It declined very sharply.
Now, as I said this curve was updated
with very different data
recently by a number,
by a team of researchers,
three of whom in that team
include the famous trio,
(mumbles) and Sukwon of Berkeley.
And the reason I mention
that is because this curve
uses different data, so it
uses tax, income tax data,
so the same data they have
used in their other work
to demonstrate that it's the top 1%
that has benefited the most
from recent economic changes.
And this curve does not look
like an elephant anymore.
I mean it looks more
like a dragon, I think.
But what it shows very clearly
is that you have a
disproportionate increase in,
well being at the top 1%.
So here, the growth incident
shows that it's the top 1%
that captured a very large
share of total growth.
However, it also makes
very clear the point
that many have made that
it's the middle class
in the US and Western
Europe that gets squeezed.
Okay, so these are the
people who benefit the least.
But still, you see that the
really poor in the world
still benefit from growth.
So the message that the
recent economic trends
have benefited the poor I
think remains still valid,
even if you use this updated curve
that paints a much less rosy picture
about what growth does for the poor.
And by the way, if you
wonder what the short
of the differences
between the two curves are
that there are many, in
my view, the main issue
is that this curve is based on tax data
that captured the very
top of the distribution.
The other curve that I showed
you is based on survey data
and there you always have the
problem that the top incomes
are not captured by these surveys.
But again, my point here is that,
any way you put it, it's
very hard to deny the message
that poverty has very sharply declined.
And it is also reflected
in this picture here,
which comes from World
Bank estimates of poverty.
So what this shows is what
has happened to poverty,
to the headcount, to the
poverty headcount over time
by different regions.
So first, if you look at the total,
you see that the total
has, we are here now,
the total has declined so the
number of poor has declined.
This is the projection
according to the World Bank
what is likely to happen by 2030.
One interesting aspect
of this graph is actually
that it's broken down by different regions
and the classifications of
the regions again reflects
the World Bank classification.
So, there are some
interesting patterns here
and one pattern is let me point out,
this part, the brown
one, this is East Asia.
In East Asia, you can see that poverty
has been almost eliminated.
This part that you can
hardly see, reddish,
is Europe and Central Asia.
And again, in these parts of the world,
poverty has been eliminated.
By the way, I forgot
to mention poverty here
is defined as living on
less than $1.9 per day.
So it's a very low bar for poverty.
So these people are
really the extremely poor,
it's a very modest
criteria but nevertheless.
Even using this criteria,
we see that if you look
at a different region,
if you look at Africa,
this is the yellow part.
Here, the picture is much, much less rosy.
Not only has poverty not declined,
poverty has increased
in Sub Saharan Africa.
In fact, it's projected to
increase even more, okay?
And the same actually applies
to this part that again,
you can hardly see because
the region is very small.
This is MENA, so this is
Middle East and North Africa.
Again, poverty is increasing there.
So poverty has declined in
many parts of the world,
but it remains very high in
Africa and the Middle East,
and in fact, there it's increasing.
So, this is in terms of,
in terms of background
of what has happened to poverty.
Now, the second point I want to make
is that I don't know, if I
have managed to convince you
that globalization was part of the story.
It's not the entire part,
there are many other things
that happened at the same time.
But we do see the fastest
poverty reductions
in precisely those parts of the world
that embrace openness and again,
East Asia comes immediately
to mind, especially China.
But that said, is what we
have experienced since 2008,
is a slowdown in trade.
So this slowdown started
after the financial crisis.
So during the financial crisis,
trade collapsed completely.
After the financial crisis,
it started growing back,
but again at a very slow pace
and it never quite gained
its previous momentum.
And some people have
attributed this slow down
to a secular slowdown.
What I mean by that is the following.
So to a certain extent, trade was fueled
by this emergence of global value chains.
And you could have global value chains
partly because it became
technologically possible
to fragment production.
And many thought at
some point fragmentation
may have run its course.
If you take a car, you
can split it into parts
and components, and you can
trade those back and forth.
But eventually you run out
of parts to split, right?
You go down to the screws,
and the nuts and bolts,
eventually you cannot fragment anymore.
So there are some who have thought,
who thought that this
may be part of the story.
And in fact, one thing
you see is if you look
at global value chains trade,
so it peaked around 2010.
And then it started going
down as a percentage of trade.
So again, with global value chain,
this is the hyperglobalization.
You see this very fast
growth during that time.
In my view, there's very little evidence
to support this view.
There's something else that
has been going on mostly
in very recent years, so
in the last five years.
And this is the very
strong policy backlash,
so the backlash against globalization.
And I think this presents
a much more serious threat
to trade and openness and
globalization in general.
So what do I mean by these?
So first, there has been
a revolt of the public
in many developed primarily countries
against free trade and immigration.
And this is not specific
to a particular country
or to a particular party.
We see it in the United States,
but if there is one issue,
whether it's bipartisan support for
is that the opposition to free trade.
You can be Donald Trump or Bernie Sanders,
and they both advocate protectionism.
Even more important than the tariffs
and the return to protectionism
has been what the US has been doing
to the World Trade Organization.
So the World Trade
Organization is by now defunct
due to the United States policies.
In the UK, we have had
Brexit, which again,
is a retreat from multilateralism.
I already mentioned the World
Trade Organization, the WTO.
In addition, despite
this generally held view
that trade is free, there has
been uneven liberalization
of agricultural trade.
Agricultural trade is
still very protected.
And this is something
that's a very big issue
for developing countries.
The services trade
remains highly restricted.
And finally, they are arising
behind what people call,
behind the border measures
and other distortions.
These are all on the rise.
So if you take all these
together, I think it's fair to say
that there has been a
retreat from globalization.
And let me show you,
again, in some pictures
what the trends are.
So this shows what has
happened to trade policy,
not trade between 1948 and 2016.
And I often use this
graph to make the point
that despite this, again broadly held view
that globalization has been
mostly technological phenomenon
fueled by low communication
and transportation costs,
I want to make the
point that trade policy,
policy has been important.
One way you see that is by seeing
what happened directly to tariffs.
So these are tariffs, applied tariffs
in developing countries.
So these types have been going down.
More importantly, if
you look at membership
in the World Trade Organization.
So this membership has gone up steadily.
And especially, what was really important
is that the World Trade Organization
included many developing countries.
And perhaps even more importantly,
we've had many regional trade agreements.
So these blue bars show the increase
in regional trade agreements.
So if you take all
these measures together;
lower tariffs, increase participation
in World Trade Organization,
in regional trade agreements,
they show that, until 2016,
they show a trend
towards more integration.
So that is to be contrasted
with what has happened post-2016.
So this is the new policy environment.
So this is the percentage of imports
that's covered by tariffs.
It's still a very small one.
So, this is for the United
States, about 12% as of 2018.
By now it's actually higher.
China, Mexico and the EU.
You may think this is still
a very low percentage,
but what's important is
that it has risen relative
to what it was five years ago.
And it's also accompanied
by certain rhetoric
that makes the future
of trade very uncertain.
Another telling graph is this one.
So it shows how many new trade agreements
were formed in recent years.
By 2018, this number had
dropped dramatically.
This is partly due to the fact
that there is enormous
uncertainty regarding the future
of trade relations.
So the world is becoming
much more closed in my view
and this is something
that I could not have said
about a year ago.
When trade tensions
first arose, my view was
that perhaps this was
just talk and negotiation.
We'll have to wait and see what happens.
But I think after two years of,
of seeing what has
happened across the world,
I do think we we are in a new regime,
where trade tensions are
going to be the new normal.
So this is on the trade
side, the policy side.
So I think in such an environment,
if you are a developing country,
if you are a developing country
that has not yet benefited
from trade with the US or Europe,
if you are a small country
in Africa, if you are Kenya,
or if you are Ghana, I
don't think you can be sure
that you can apply the same model
of export led industrialization
that apply to China,
I don't think you can bet on
this for your future growth.
An additional challenge
is that many countries
are confronted with new technologies.
And there is a general fear that robots
are going to make low wage labor
in developing countries redundant.
So remember, one of the big advantages
of developing countries has
always been that they can offer
low wage labor.
If low wage labor becomes less important
because firms can rely on machines,
then developing countries
are going to lose
this disadvantage they have had.
That said, I have to say that so far
we have not seen any
evidence of (mumbles).
So this is based actually on some work
we did in the World Bank last year
in the context of their
World Development Report.
And let me just show you this graph
that contradicts what
I just said actually.
So what this graph shows is that,
and again it's a correlation
for the most part.
The horizontal axis you
have industries are ordered
according to the right
intensity of using robots.
So for example, here
the automobile industry
uses robots very intensively,
followed by rubber and
plastics, metal, and so on.
And so what we found is
that those industries
that use robots very intensively
are actually the industries
that also experience the
fastest growth of imports
from developing countries.
And these imports are imports
in intermediate products and parts.
Essentially, the story
behind this is that,
by using robots, you
increase productivity.
And as firms become more
productive and grow,
they need more intermediate
parts, more components,
and these they still get
from developing countries.
So that's why I said this fear that robots
will render trade with
developing countries redundant
has not materialized yet.
But it's still a fear that
we meet in the horizon
because so far robots
have not been applied
in developing countries themselves.
So of course, the problem becomes
if in developing countries,
you can use robots
to produce the parts and the components,
then eventually jobs in these countries
are going to be threatened as well.
So we have not seen that yet
but it's still a fear that's out there.
So that creates this
need for the new vision
that I spoke off.
So this is something that one
is immediately confronted with
if one joins an organization
like the World Bank these days.
And again to summarize the main point,
there are two main challenges
that countries face.
So, developing countries,
poor countries face.
One is there is this
backlash against free trade
in developed countries.
To put it bluntly, many
developed countries
are closing their borders.
So, if you are a poor country,
you cannot really count on
your exports to be welcome
in richer countries.
And at the same time, there
is a fear of automation
that may render low wage jobs redundant.
And on top of that, I
would say there is also
a lot of competition among
developing countries.
So if you are in Kenya and you try
to get into the export market
or into the US export market,
you face competition from Ethiopia,
you face competition from
Bangladesh, from Vietnam.
It's a very competitive
space at this point.
So again, this background,
these are old model of development.
So what's the old model?
Export led industrialization.
So what seems to have
worked for China or Korea
or Vietnam is questionable.
And that raises the question,
what is the alternative?
So, if this is not going to work,
what is likely to work for countries?
So, let me now come into
some of the alternatives
that have been proposed
in the development world.
So, the first one is what people call,
leapfrogging into services.
The idea there is to leap directly
from agricultural to the service sector.
So, bypassing the stage of manufacturing.
So, the problem with this
is, so far I have not seen
a legal theoretical
framework and by theoretical,
I don't necessarily mean many equations
but some conceptual
framework that clarifies
how exactly this is supposed to work.
On the empirical side,
there are many challenges
if you think about how
this model may work.
So for one, services is a very broad
and heterogeneous category.
So when we talk about services,
we talk about tourists
but we also talk about
financial and business services.
You may talk about driving
a car or being a hairdresser
or you may talk about being
a lawyer or an accountant.
So it's a very heterogeneous category.
In addition, so far,
there has been no evidence
of leapfrogging in any country.
And again, there, I'm going to rely
on the World Development Report of 2020.
And that was actually one
of the interesting takeaways
from this report.
And let me show you what this graph shows
because I think it's one of
the most interesting graphs
in this report.
So what this graph shows
is how fast countries grow
once they join,
once they're set to joint
global value chains.
And they can join global
value chains in various ways.
So, you can join by participating
in what what we call
limited manufacturing.
So, limited manufacturing
is producing products
that require low skill and low wages.
So, like textiles, shoes,
the kind of products
that still Vietnam or Ethiopia produce.
Then in blue you can have
countries participating
by joining advanced
manufacturing and services.
And by advanced
manufacturing, we mean cars,
so, automobiles, machinery,
chemicals, so, products
that require more educated,
a more educated labor
force and more capital.
Then in purple, you have innovative,
in red, you have innovative activities.
And these are the kinds of activities
that the more advanced,
the richest countries participate in.
So these include any product that,
or services that require a
highly skilled labor force.
And they also include, mostly services.
So they include mostly things like design
and research and so on.
So, you can see, how fast
countries grow once they join
these global value chains
in one of its forms.
And so, the fastest growth is seen
when countries join through
limited manufacturing.
So that says that from the
time they join year zero,
20 years later, they have
the per capita income,
this is all per capita, has
grown cumulatively by 57%.
So this is a huge number.
So this is essentially
the story of Vietnam here.
Then if you are in blue,
it shows what happens
if you join through advanced manufacturing
and again, you grow very fast
but a little, at a lower pace by 48%.
And in the last case, you
grow by 32% and again,
this is what you would expect,
because countries who
join here, the red part,
these are countries that are already rich.
So it's harder to actually
become richer and richer,
it's harder to grow fast.
So it makes sense that
these numbers are lower.
And another thing to
point out about this graph
is countries can be present
in all the three graphs, why?
Because they may move from one to another.
So for example, one example is Korea.
South Korea started here in the green part
and eventually moved to the blue part
by participating more
advanced manufacturing,
cars and so on, and by
now it's in the red part.
Okay, so countries transition
across the three parts.
So when I show this graph,
many people ask immediately the question,
so do we see countries leapfrogging?
So go directly from being
an agricultural country,
leapfrogging directly to the red part.
And this is, if you're in the
World Bank, for many people,
this is the vision for the future,
that you are in Africa, you're in Kenya,
you're in Ethiopia, and
rather than industrializing
and getting to the green part,
you are going to jump right
into the red part, right?
And the fact is that we
don't have a single case,
a single country where
we've seen that in the past.
So of course, the fact that
this hasn't happened in the past
doesn't mean cannot happen in the future.
But the fact is, we've never seen it.
So the most successful example is Korea
and Korea spent again
time in all three parts,
but it spent very little
time with the green part.
So very few years in limited manufacturing
and eventually jumped to
advanced manufacturing.
But we don't see in the data.
We've never seen a case
where a country managed
to go directly from being an agricultural,
an agrarian setting to going
to being an advanced economy,
specializing services and
innovative activities.
So I'm not, again, I don't want to say
that this cannot happen, but
we don't have any evidence
and we don't have any theory
to support this so far.
The second view that you often
hear about is urbanization.
And again, development has
often, has traditionally been,
traditionally go hand in
hand with urbanization.
And we do see increasing urbanization
in many developing countries.
Even in Africa, we see the
emergence of big cities.
However, again, the
evidence here suggests that,
again, to borrow a term from a paper
by Gollin, by Dan Gollin who was here
and Jedwab and Vollrath,
in many cases, what we see in Africa
is urbanization without industrialization.
And when we see that in cities in Africa,
then we find that the
emergence of the cities
is not associated with any
good development outcomes.
So what they show in this
paper by calling at all
is that these cities, they are large,
but the poverty rates are still high,
the educational levels are
high and any measure you use,
any traditional measure of
development or a wellbeing,
by any measure the cities
are not doing very well.
And one point they make in this paper
is there is a difference between
what they call consumption
and production cities.
And consumption cities
are cities associated
with higher poverty.
Consumption cities are cities
where there are a lot of services,
but these are consumption services.
So you have many hairdressers
and drivers and the end.
You have many people
working in these professions
that are classified as
services but they don't seem
to be contributing to poverty reduction.
And this is to be contrasted
with the so-called production services
that are associated with trade
that tend to be associated
with better development outcomes.
So the point they make in
this paper is that somehow
in Africa cities cannot play this role
of being agents of development,
partly because they concentrate
on these consumption services.
So now I want to come
to the third hypothesis,
the third view that,
I think deserves further exploration.
And this relates to the
following intuitive idea
that if international trade
is not going to be the engine
of growth in the future,
simply because of the political reality,
then perhaps the domestic
market will be asked
to play a more important role.
And there I would like to start
with some casual observation.
So one observation is that
India has been growing fast.
We don't know how fast
because of all the issues with the data.
No one knows exactly what the numbers are.
But the one thing that I think
it's safe to say is that growth
in India has not been driven
by trade for sure.
Now, India is a very large country.
So it's a country where
the large domestic market
could potentially support growth, why?
Because a large economy
can support internal economies of scale.
A counterexample is Nigeria.
So Nigeria is also a large
country, not as large as India.
But it's a large country, is
very rich in natural resources.
It's reaching people, it
has a large population,
and it has had periods of fast growth,
mainly when oil prices go up,
but there has been no
sustained development
and no poverty reduction.
And so, if you contrast these examples,
one striking difference between the two
is the degree of inequality
and this is not to say that
India is an equal economy,
not at all.
But Nigeria is well known for
the high degree of inequality,
so essentially wealth is concentrated
in the hands of very few.
And so when there is a positive shock,
for example, high oil
prices that translate
to fast aggregate growth, this
growth never trickles down,
or it trickles down in
the form that Gollin
and Toill described.
So you have some reach, you
have a very small reach class.
They become richer because
oil prices are high.
They build nice homes, they
need construction workers,
they need drivers, they need hairdressers,
they need housekeepers,
these services increase,
these are consumption services.
So you have aggregate growth,
but you don't have sustained
poverty reduction, right?
So that leads to that to
this additional hypothesis
that perhaps this high inequality
is actually a constraint
to growth and poverty reduction.
And cases like Nigeria or Angola are cases
where they've exemplified this story.
So, I try to explain this
story using one or two examples
but of course, these
are one, two examples.
And so one question is how do
we operationalize this idea?
And what exactly does it mean to say,
we have a large market
and what's the meaning of
equality in this context?
How equal is an equal?
What exactly is development?
And how large does the market need to be
in order for these
mechanisms to be relevant?
And last but not least, so
I gave the example of India
but if a country is not
India, if a country is small,
what are you supposed to do?
This is not going to be, I'm
not going to make the case here
for countries trying
to expand through war,
to create Lebensraum, not at all.
But my point is that one
needs a conceptual framework
to think about these issues.
And that actually brings me to some work,
a paper I've been working on recently.
And that perhaps is not
a good way to structure
this talk in the sense
that I'm transitioning
from either talk like myself
from what I've done in the World
Bank to more academic work.
I just want to give you an idea so far
of what the motivation for
this academic work was.
So, this is, by the way,
this is a joint project
with Tristan Reed which here,
he said the World Bank and we
have a preliminary draft out.
The idea behind this paper is inspired
by an paper by Murphy
Shleifer, envisioning from '89
but that's actually a
paper that makes the case
for the importance of the domestic market
a nd a certain degree of equality.
So this is not their famous
paper on the big push
in the JP, this is an earlier paper.
And that paper itself
formalized some of the ideas
that had been in development
for a very long time before.
So, most importantly, by Arthur Lewis,
but also by (mumbles) and other people,
and I don't want to try
to cover all of them
because I'm sure I will forget many.
But the point is that these
ideas were out in development
for a very long time and the
paper by Murphy and Toill
actually formalized these ideas.
And this paper gives rise
to an empirical threshold
crossing model that we estimate
using a methodology
very much in the spirit
of present (mumbles), other
famous paper in the JP,
the entry paper.
So we estimate this model using panel data
from multiple countries.
And we use it to calculate,
among various other things,
how large a market needs to be,
in order to rely on itself,
to benefit from domestic
economies of scale
without relying on trade.
So let me with the remaining
time, which is not much,
let me outline what this
theoretical framework looks like.
I'm not going to show any equations here,
but I'll give you the general idea.
It's a highly stylized
model, but I just want
to convey the main idea.
So, imagine you have a closed economy.
And this can be relaxed,
but the closed economy case
is here relevant, because
I want to focus precisely
on the case where trade
is not important anymore.
Imagine you have two sectors;
agricultural and manufacturing.
What do the preferences look like?
There is an agricultural good
food and this is a necessity.
The consumer spend all
their income on food
until they receive a
minimal subsistence level.
This is called Z.
For income levels above Z,
consumers can afford to buy manufacturers.
It's assumed that there is a
well defined ordering of goods
in terms of desirability.
So, once you are above
the subsistence level,
you start buying some goods
and then as you become richer
you buy goods of higher desirability.
And so as consumption
increases, what in this model,
this highly stylized model,
what increases is not
the quantity of the goods you consume,
what increases is the
variety of goods you consume,
the range of goods.
In terms of technology,
there are two inputs;
land and labor.
Land is a fixed factor.
So, as a result, there
are decreasing returns
to scale in agriculture.
And then in manufacturing
that's important,
there are two technologies.
There is a constant
returns to scale technology
that has no fixed costs.
And there is also an increasing
returns to scale technology
that has fixed costs but
lower variable costs.
So, firms have a choice, they can,
if they want to produce manufactured goods
they can produce using
the constant returns
to scale technology, or
they can use the IRS,
increasing return to scale technology.
And industrialization
in this setup is defined
as the transition from the
constant returns to scale
to the IRS technology.
The market structure is
as follows in agriculture,
you have perfect competition
in manufacturing.
If you produce with a
back stop technology,
there is perfect competition.
But if you are in manufacturing,
and you produce with the IRS technology,
so if you are industrialized,
then there are monopoly,
there is a monopoly, the monopoly rents
and the monopoly rents actually play
an important role in this model.
And finally, that's important,
that that's the appealing
feature of this model.
It's assumed that there
is poverty and inequality
to start with.
Poverty here is defined
as follows, the wage,
there is only one wage in the economy.
The wage in agriculture is
the same as in manufacturing.
And this wage is below
the subsistence level.
So if all you do is being
a worker in agriculture,
then you can't buy
manufacturers and you're poor.
You don't have enough to eat.
On the other hand and there's also
a very high degree of
inequality in the sense
that most people are laborers.
So they rely only on the labor
income, and they're poor.
However, there is also a
fraction in this population
that owns land rents and shares.
And so this is the structure.
And then what they show is
that with these assumptions,
you can have an equilibrium,
it's actually a unique equilibrium
with industrialization.
And in this equilibrium,
you have the monopolies,
they show that the monopolist
will adopt the IRS technology,
when the variable costs, when
the profits are positive.
And that means that the
variable profits are high enough
to cover the fixed costs.
So in the margin sector of the
economy, the variable profits
are going to be exactly
equal to the fixed costs.
So this is exactly what gives rise
to this breakeven condition
and for those of you
familiar with the model,
you see now why I said
this is very similar
to the setup in Bresnahan and Reiss.
In Bresnahan and Reiss
they estimate thresholds,
market threshold sizes
for a duopoly to enter,
for more firms to enter market.
Here, we don't do that but here
we simply asked the question
how large does a market need
to be for the monopolist
to view this IRS technology as desirable.
So to switch from the CRS
to the IRS technology.
Now, variable profits
themselves depend on sales.
So sales have to be large
enough to cover the fixed costs.
So denote by N star, the
minimum efficient scale.
Then the sales are going
to depend on two things
in this setup.
They're going to depend on the
size of the domestic market.
And so that's why a large
domestic market is going to help
but they also depend on the
size of the middle class.
So now introduce another
term here, middle class,
what's the middle class in this model?
So middle class is the number of consumers
who are not very poor.
So they have enough money
to buy manufacturers
but they are not so
rich that they buy only
a few luxury goods that
you can actually produce
with this backstop technology.
So they're actually the
consumers that have incomes
between the subsistence level
and between the minimum
efficient scale, okay?
So in other words, what
happens in this economy
is if you are really poor,
if you rely only on your wage
that's below the subsistence level,
then you just buy food, nothing else.
If you have some shares
in land or in industry,
within this realization, then you can buy,
you use your first Z units
of your income to buy food.
Once you've reached the subsistence level,
you use the next income to
buy industrialized goods.
So goods that are produced at mass scale.
And then if you have even more money,
if you're in the upper
class, if you're truly rich,
that's the upper class, then you buy food,
you buy these goods
that are mass produced,
the goods that are also
bought by the middle class.
But you also buy the backstop,
you also buy the luxury goods
that are produced with a constant returns
to scale technology.
So I think this model has, in my view,
it's very simple, very stylized,
but it has a number of
very attractive features,
because you can use it to explain
what's happening in many
developing countries.
So if you think about Nigeria,
the example I gave you before,
so this is a case where the middle class
is relatively small.
So you have resources,
but you have the very poor
buying just food and then
you have the very rich
buying just luxury goods.
So goods that you don't produce,
they're not mass produced
with IRS technology.
And, in these cases,
you end up with these
consumption services and growth
that doesn't trickle down.
So I think it very much,
you can use that to explain
what happens in many developing countries.
Now, what are the
implications for development?
You can apply this model
to tell a story about
structural transformation
that looks as follows.
So a poor country, take
again the example I gave you,
Nigeria, needs an initial boost.
So you need something that is going
to create resources wealth effect.
And this can be an increase
in agricultural productivity.
This is again something
that the early development
literature often emphasize
that you need agricultural
productivity to increase,
otherwise, you don't have,
you cannot have enough resources free
from agriculture to go to manufacturing.
But alternatively, you
can also have exports
of natural resources.
For example, in the case of
Nigeria, you can have oil.
And that's where the model
becomes a little more,
allows for a little openness in the sense
that in order to export
oil you need to be,
you need to be trading
with another country.
But here trade in that case
has a very specific function.
It's not a case where you use trade
to tap into foreign markets
and exploit economies of scale,
you just use trade to generate
this initial wealth effect.
To just bring revenue into the country
and this is the only function
that these oil revenues have, okay?
So, you have this wealth
effect, and this wealth effect
can jumpstart the process of
structural transformation, how?
So, take the case of agricultural
productivity increasing,
then the wages rise both
because productivity increases,
and because there is more demand
for labor in agricultural.
Then the rents rise and labor move
from agriculture to manufacturing.
As manufacturing expands,
agricultural shrinks.
So this is the process
of industrialization.
And so the main insights of
this model is that what you need
for industrialization
to happen is you need
this initial boost.
So, this can be as I said
agricultural productivity
or initial growth in exports.
You need to have a large domestic market
and you also need a
certain degree of equality,
and here equality is interpreted
in a very specific way.
What you need is the middle class,
you need people with
enough purchasing power
that are going to support
producing products
at mass scale and taking advantage
of decreasing returns to scale.
Okay, so one question you may have is, so,
here industrialization and
development are synonyms
in this model, and one
question is why does this lead
to poverty reduction, which
is what I'm interested in.
So directly there is an effect
because the more the wages increase
as wages increase, eventually,
the living standards
of the poor improve and
they may rise above poverty.
In addition profits increase.
And so, the living standards
of the small shareholders
to the extent of the small shareholders
may be below the poverty
line also improve.
But there are also reasons
that are outside the model.
So, for example, there may
be technological spillovers
associated with industrialization.
So, these are not in the
model, but in other literature,
they've been shown to be
very important for growth.
And empirically,
industrialization has always
been associated with development.
So, you can rely on this
empirical observation.
So, this is sort of the theoretical
background of the model.
So this theory structure leads
to threshold crossing model
that looks as follows.
That's again very simple.
The profit, the increasing
return to sector
are given as follows.
The market size times per
capita variable profit.
So these are the variable
profits minus fixed costs.
So follow again, that's
the part that's inspired
by Bresnahan and Reiss.
The beauty of Bresnahan and Reiss
is they could estimate an entry model
without using data on prices,
which are very hard to get.
Of course, I know Steve is going to say
this is a huge weakness of
this literature and I agree,
but if you are trying to
think about poverty here
for 100 countries, this
becomes an advantage
because you can try to
relay all these entities
I talked about, variable
profits or fixed costs
to market observables rather than prices.
So we model here market size
as a function of observables.
And similarly, variable profit
as a function of demand,
observables and cost, demand
variables and cost variables
and same thing with fixed costs.
And a firm is going to
enter the IRS sector.
So it's going to adopt
this new technology,
if the variable profits
exceed the fixed costs,
and so that gives rise
to this empirical model.
So, let me now come to the part
that makes a direct
connection to the empirics.
As I said, we model all these things,
variable profits or fixed costs
as functions of observables.
And these observables are as follows.
So, in terms of market size,
so we define market size
as a function of the following variables.
So, the population of the
country in terms of raw bodies
and in particular in this specification
is how many people are,
people who don't have the purchasing power
of the middle class.
Then the market size
also depends on the share
of the middle class and I
will tell you in a moment
how we define that.
And in addition, we take
into account the fact
that if you actually take
this model to the data,
in reality, most countries
are not closed, right?
In the model I presented, we
started with a stylized case
of a closed economy, but actually,
most countries are open to trade.
So then to take that into account,
we define two measures of integration.
One is based on summing up the
populations of all countries
with which a particular
countries integrated with
and the other one is based on the,
on summing up all the
incomes of the countries
with which a country is integrated with.
So that's actually I think, one
of the biggest contributions
of this work, the way
we define integration,
so in order to see which
countries are integrated
with others, we exploit
information on participation
in the World Trade Organization.
GAD but also many
regional trade agreements
and we relied on some
work by other authors
that actually went down all
the regional trade agreements
and go down the legal
provisions in each case,
which case there were legal provisions
that connected countries.
So, if there is a legal provision
connecting two countries,
then we assign an indicator equal to one
and then we use that to form weights
summing up all the countries.
So the main, I will try to
avoid getting into the details
given time constraints, but the main point
I want to make here is that we end up
using two different measures
of international integration.
And one base is based on the idea
that when you connect
with other countries,
you may connect with other countries
that are very large in population.
So this way you get access
to a lot of consumers,
but there is an also
an alternative measure
that rely to the notion that
you connect with countries
that may be very rich,
they may have high income.
And this is also viable,
because you may connect to countries
that are small in terms of
population, but they're very,
that they have large purchasing power.
So in terms of the per
capita variable profits,
there again, we, the choice of variables
is very much informed by
the model in the sense
that we use past export growth
and also past agricultural
productivity growth
as observables that may lead
to higher variable profits.
And finally, when it
comes to the fixed costs,
that's when we rely on
the very large literature
on institutions in developing countries,
which suggests that variables
such as the tropical climate,
the desert climate, distance
to the coast, ruggedness
and also legal origins,
whether they're British legal origins
or French Typical origins have an impact
to how well a country is run,
which in turn may have effect
on the size of the fixed costs.
So these are the observables
we use and again there,
you can think of many robustness checks
and many alternative definitions.
The dependent variable we use in this work
is sustained poverty reduction.
And so, this is, so, in other words,
the question we are asking is,
can we we relay sustained
poverty reduction
to industrialization?
And if so, how large
does a market need to be
for this process to be relevant?
So, in order to do that we need
to find we need to define
what sustained poverty reduction is.
And without again, going into the details,
I'll just give you a brief overview.
We use the POVCALNET.
This is a computational tool
developed by the World Bank
that allows you to compute poverty rates
for many different countries.
We use that to compute poverty
rates for particular years.
And then in some cases,
we have to interpolate
given missing data.
And then we break up our
data into five-year periods.
And then we look, we
look at whether poverty
has declined in every single
year in this five-year period.
So if poverty has declined
every year in five-year period,
then for this period, we
assign a variable equal to one,
saying that during that period,
we had sustained poverty reduction, right?
If poverty declines in the first two years
and then goes up in the
next year, then we assign
a value equal to zero to this measure
of sustained poverty reduction.
So in other words, what
we try to do and again,
there are many different ways to do that,
but one has to start somewhere is to say,
do we see countries reducing poverty
over a period of time every single year?
If so, then we call that
sustained poverty reduction.
Okay, so this is going to
be our dependent variable.
So let me show you, some
patterns in the data
that I think quite interesting.
So we have a total of 93 countries.
We exclude countries that have
already eliminated poverty.
So these are the advanced countries
or all countries that have
poverty rates below 3%.
And again poverty is defined
in terms of extreme poverty,
so being below the 1.9 threshold.
And what this table shows you
is how sustained real
per capita GDP growth
relates to sustained
extreme poverty reduction.
So what we did for poverty,
you can also do for growth,
for per capita growth, income growth.
You can take per capita income growth
and see if it,
if there is growth every single period,
then you would call it sustained
per capita income growth.
So, as you would expect,
growth and poverty reduction
are highly correlated, and this is a point
that people have often made,
growth is important for
poverty, this is undeniable.
So, 76%, if we see poverty
reduction in 76% of the cases,
this is also accompanied by growth.
However, there are also many
cases, so 82 in particular
out of the 347, where you do have growth
but you don't see poverty reduction.
So growth doesn't automatically
generate poverty reduction.
And we see these, these
are all cases in countries
that are extremely unequal.
So, again Nigeria comes to mind .
These are cases where you
make up very fast growth
usually fueled by commodity prices,
but then this growth never trickles down.
So this is the first thing to show.
The second is again showing the data
on sustained extreme poverty reduction.
So here, what we graphed is how many cases
of sustained poverty reduction
do you have over time
in various parts of the world.
And the first thing that jumps
out if you look at this graph
is how high the percentages associated
with sustained poverty reduction are.
So most of the numbers are well above 50%.
So here, for many countries
in 86% of these country
five-year pairs, you see
sustained poverty reduction.
And again, this speaks to the fact
that there has been enormous progress made
so we do see poverty reduction over time.
Our data, by the way,
are from 1980 to 2015.
There are some other things
that I think are quite interesting.
If you look at the period 2006 to 2010,
so this is post-financial crisis.
This is still a period where
poverty goes down very fast
in many parts of the world.
And that again shows
that advanced countries,
developing countries are
not always synchronized.
So even though the advanced countries,
the industrialized world
was in a major crisis,
there were still progress made
in many developing countries.
Some cases that really
stand out is Africa.
Again, Sub Saharan Africa until '96,
you have hardly any poverty reduction.
And again, this is well known.
In other cases, Latin America,
which is more puzzling.
And we think that has
more to do with the data.
Let me also show you some patterns
on international integration
that I think are quite interesting.
As I mentioned, there are two measures
of international integration.
One captures the size of
the international market,
the integrated market as
measured by population,
and the other one as measured by income.
By relative income.
And so what we do here is
actually we construct a variable
that measures integration
in relative terms.
So what's the size of the
market in terms of population
that you connect with
relative to your own market?
These are all in relative terms.
So one thing you see is
starting in 2000, around 2000,
in almost the entire world,
the integrated market jumps up, right?
So in terms of population,
countries are connecting
to much larger market.
So what's going on here is very,
very simply, this is China,
You connect to China, you
connect to a very large market,
but at the same time, see what happens.
If you define this integration
measure in terms of income,
then it goes down.
And again, that's a
graphical way of portraying
the entry of China.
This is another way to
see that very clearly.
It's again, 2001, this
is just for countries
that are members of the
World Trade Organization.
So in 2001, in terms of
population, there is a jump.
It seems that countries are connecting
the relative integrated
market in terms of population
becomes much larger than before
because China enters the
World Trade Organization.
But in terms of income,
you have this huge jump,
but then the income in China rises.
And so then again, the
relative income rises.
So this is one way of
portraying what has happened,
but at the same time, you can
also see what the concern is.
So if you're a developing
country, you connect with China,
all of a sudden you're
connecting with a competitor
rather than a country to which
you can send your exports.
So, the reason I think this
is important is when you,
I'll skip that because
there's no time left
but I'll tell you very briefly
what eventually our
empirical results show.
The empirical results
show that the market size
is very important for
expanding poverty reduction.
And market size, as I said,
is defined by three variables.
So the population, the total
population is important.
International integration is important.
And when we look at international
integration, actually,
what's most important is
how rich the countries
you connect with are.
So, connecting two countries
with higher relative income
is much more valuable than
connecting to countries
with large populations.
That's what the results suggest.
Suggest to give you some numbers.
If you connect with a country
that has the same relative
population, as you do on average,
it's like adding 160,000
people to your country.
If you connect with a country
that has the same
relative income as you do,
then it's like connected,
it's like adding 20 million
people to your population.
So the income, the relative
income is much more important.
And this has direct implications.
So to give you an example,
Kenya is a country
that right now is considering,
should we engage in a bilateral agreement
with the United States?
Or should we be focused more
in a pan-African trade agreement?
If you take these results,
they suggest it's much
more valuable for Kenya
to connect to the United
States, which is a rich economy,
rather than relying on the African market.
Again, this is not surprising.
This is what Korea did and
this is what China did.
And this is what the results
of the model also say,
actually quantitative terms,
they suggest huge effects.
Now, of course, the problem
is that it's not clear
that all these countries can connect
to the United States anymore, right?
So so what we're saying
is if you cannot connect
to the United States,
maybe the alternative
is to connect to your neighbors
that may not be as rich
but they have a very large population,
and this is not as viable,
but it's still viable
compared to the alternative
of being completely closed.
So you can take these
results as giving you
some sense of how important
regional integration may be
in that setting.
But finally, and I want to stop with that
because this is more in
the spirit of Kuznets.
Finally, we consider one counterfactual,
which is the strongest one where we say,
suppose there is no integration at all.
So not only can't you connect
with the United States,
but you cannot even connect
with your neighbors.
And this is not so far fetched,
because many developing
countries view the neighbors
as big competitors, so they're
not willing to engage in,
in trade cooperation.
And so if you just rely
on the domestic market,
how large does this
domestic market have to be
so that you can have sustained
poverty reduction, okay?
And so the number we get out of,
this is the threshold is 328 million.
So these are 3328 million enrolled bodies,
so people that are below
the middle class, okay?
So think of those as being
328 million poor people.
So, the only country
that meets these criteria
is India, right?
There is no one else.
And this is something that actually
the graph shows.
Now, the reason this is not so bleak is,
if you don't have 328 million raw bodies,
you can still meet this
threshold by increasing,
by having a middle class by
increasing the purchasing power
of the people within your country.
So this is one way of
transforming a raw body
to someone who can actually consume more.
And so, again, to give
you a specific example,
take the case of Norway.
Norway found oil in the late 1960s.
At that point already Norway
was a fairly equal society.
It's a very small country.
It's not a country that has
relied on trade to grow,
it's not a country that has
a very large domestic market,
a very large population.
But it's a country that has always had
a very high degree of equality.
I forget what the exact
population of Norway is.
It's certainly not 300 million.
But if you actually,
according to our estimates,
if you go from zero
percent, that's middle class
to 100% middle class,
in the average country,
this is like adding 540 million people.
So if your middle class increases by 10%,
then it's like adding 54
poor people in the country.
So, ultimately, what
this suggests is that if
we end up in a world where
we have much less trade
and much less regional integration,
so with open trade, it's still
going to be the first choice.
It's extremely important
for developing countries.
And the smaller the country,
the more important it is.
But if that's not an option,
if you have to rely more
on the domestic market,
what are the options
not to have war in order to race,
to enlarge your country?
You may argue, some might argue,
you may want higher fertility
to increase your population.
This would be a very perverse
way to justify all this,
sometimes we have this policy to try
to actually increase population.
Tanzania is one example, where
there is a very strong policy
where the current head of the state
is encouraging people to have more kids.
But of course, this creates
all kinds of other problems.
So if you're not going
to advocate any of these,
then an alternative is to try
to create a more equal society
with larger middle class,
because by adding middle class
you add purchasing power.
And again, this is not something new here.
Many people have made the point before
that the middle class may be important,
but here using this framework,
we can actually quantify
how important this is.
And finally, how do you
create a middle class?
So, again, in this model that we have,
there is a very direct mapping
between the theoretical structure
and the policy implications,
which is the way you create it
is to sort of extend by taxing
income, but more importantly,
by a more equitable
distribution of shares.
So, it actually, it's an argument in favor
of wealth redistribution, more
than income redistribution.
And I will stop here
but I want to make sure
that this last comment is not interpreted
as advocacy for the wealth tax.
I want to make clear
that this is an argument
that I think may be very
relevant in very poor countries,
countries like Angola or Nigeria,
where you have a very large
share of the population
owning next to nothing.
And in this country,
there is a certain degree
of redistribution from the
rich to the middle class,
but also to the poor may
ultimately be a precondition
for growth, rather than
an impediment to growth.
So I will stop here, thank you
very much for your patience.
(audience applauding)
- So we're a bit short on time
but we'll take a couple of questions.
(speaks off-mic)
- Thank you very much for this diverse
and insightful lecture.
I have two questions,
but feel free to shorten
if you want to take more.
One is that in the beginning,
you said, trade helped growth
in Asia very much, but not so
much in Sub Saharan Africa.
And I was interested in what you think
are the most convincing
explanations for that phenomenon?
And secondly, when we
argue that we should invest
in a global middle class,
how do you think will that,
might that be an issue
with current debates
on the limits to that sort
of consumption globally
with regards to environmental concerns?
- I'll take three questions and then...
- Welcome back, thank
you for being with us.
I just had a question, speaking
about the elephant curves,
dragon curves, more inequality.
Also, there has been very
much, much lower confidence
in the Bretton Woods institutions.
And my question is referring
to the Andersen et al paper,
which was published on the
World Bank website 10 days ago
and speaking about this whole
idea of foreign aid capture.
My question is, what do
you think about that paper?
I thought it was stunning that it showed
all those correlations between
World Bank, dispersions
and higher levels of
offshore capital accounts
by like seven and a half percent.
What's your view towards that?
I also totally understand
that if your hand is tied
for the next 72 hours, thank you.
- Okay, so let me answer these
questions if there are more.
So regarding the role of trade.
So Africa has not traded much
with the rest of the world
the way East Asia had.
So it's not that trade
did not help Africa,
is that trade has not happened in Africa
the way it has happened in East Asia
to the extent that trade
has been present in Africa.
For the most part, it has been in the form
of commodity exports.
And I think that that is very,
the story there is very
consistent with the one
I just presented.
Namely, you have commodity exports,
they generate export revenue.
But the growth these
export revenues create
never trickles down,
it doesn't trickle down
because it stays in the hands of very few.
That's certainly the story
that you hear for Nigeria
or Angola, but many other countries,
that it's not growth that trickles down.
In Asia, it was a very different story
where trade not only took
advantage of the low wage labor
in China or Korea or
Taiwan and they, of course,
also took advantage of the rich markets
in the United States and
Europe but in addition to that,
the resources they amassed
through trade or exports
were invested very differently
in these countries.
They were investing to
fund infrastructure,
substantial physical infrastructure,
but also human capital infrastructure.
So they did make these investments
that were very important
for growth and ultimately,
poverty reduction.
So the developing experiences,
two parts of the world
were very, very different.
I'm sorry, the second question was?
On consumption.
Ah, that's a good question.
So I'll tell you my view.
So when no one talks
about trade these days,
and especially, trade as it
relates to the middle class
and the consumption of the middle class,
there's immediately push back.
Because if developing
countries grow the same way
that developed countries
have grown in the past,
this is going to put a lot of
pressure on the environment.
And that's for sure.
Two thoughts on these.
First, if you actually look at where
the most of the pollution is,
it's concentrated on some very
large developing countries,
mostly China and India.
So one could gain a lot, one
could make great progress
in addressing these issues
just by focusing on these two countries.
And China is by no means,
it's not a developed country,
but it's by no means a
country that cannot make
a serious effort in
addressing these issues.
I think when it comes to
countries in Sub Saharan Africa,
so countries like still
Kenya or Ethiopia or Mali,
or Chad, countries where the poverty rates
are extremely high still.
Where you have 30% of the population
living under the poverty rate,
or when you have a country like Niger
where you have the median
age of the population
is 15 years, 15 years.
Imagine what this means.
Then in my view, climate
change is not a priority
in this country.
So when you go there and you say,
developing a middle
class or growth or trade
is not that important, you
should have second thoughts
about all these because it's
bad for the environment.
I mean, not only do I think
this is not effective,
I think it's more for us to be saying that
to these countries when
we don't do our part.
So I think we should
start with, of course,
the advanced economies to the extent
that you go to developing
countries, China and India
before we go to sub Saharan Africa
and talk about climate change there.
Regarding the elite capture paper,
so I don't want to talk
about this paper simply
because this is not the
topic of the Kuznets lecture.
I mean, institutions are
important for development,
that's for sure.
In the framework I just
showed you institutions
are indirectly measured
by the fixed costs.
And we do find that they play
a very important role in development.
I mean, one issue that
not just the World Bank,
the development community has always faced
is when it comes to development.
Everyone always says
institutions are important,
you can't make progress
unless you fix institutions.
But no one as a recipe of
how to fix institutions.
What is the right policy?
How do you do better?
I think what research has shown
that perhaps the only constructive
insight in that regard
is the only thing that
helps is transparency.
I do think that the
World Bank should follow
the same policies it advises
other countries to follow
namely be completely transparent.
Regarding this paper, I'm
gonna just make one comment.
If you actually look at the
aid affected by all this,
it's a very small percentage, it's 7%.
So whatever the paper is,
I don't think it speaks
to a big issue in development.
(Rohini speaking off-mic)
(audience applauding)
(closing music)